climbing frames like this Americans call
them jungle gyms they used to be all
over in kids playgrounds and schools
around the world these days they've
mostly been replaced by designs that are
a little less geometric and perhaps a
little more safe but this this is the
first one someone had to invent it and
that someone was called Sebastian Hinton
technically there was at least one
prototype before this one but this was
the first solidly constructed modern
climbing frame the type that was sold
under the trademark name of jungle gym
it was installed at a school here in
Winnetka near Chicago in 1920 was used
for 90 years including being relocated
to another school and it now sits here
in the Winnetka historical society's
Back Garden
I'm not allowed to climb up this by the
way partly because it's historic and
partly because I really don't think my
U.S medical insurance would cover
someone in his 30s falling off a jungle
gym
now this was a pretty good invention for
the time as the patent says the
facilities for climbing available to the
average child are limited and generally
speaking somewhat dangerous I have
rejected I don't know why I'm doing with
that voice he was American in the early
20th century he wouldn't have sounded
like that
I have reduced the danger of climbing to
a minimum for 1920 he was probably right
but he is optimistic the patent mentions
that you might tie some ropes across the
bottom to help catch a kid if they fall
or put fence wire around the outside or
even put it around a swimming pool but
us that's probably not needed a child
falling in the structure will have so
many opportunities to catch a bar or
vertical that it is almost impossible
that he will fold Through It To The
Ground the idea of a child slipping
hitting their head and then ragdolling
down to the floor doesn't seem to have
occurred to him but he does emphasize
safety and that it must be constructed
with the strength to handle dozens of
children swinging around on it together
he covered his bases the text of the
patent expands to cover basically any
arrangement of perpendicular pipes like
these there's also a reference in there
to playing three-dimensional tag and
that's where the story gets interesting
for me because while Sebastian Hinton
patented this he got the idea from his
father mathematician Charles Hinton
Charles has an interesting biography he
was fascinated with the idea of the
fourth dimension he wrote the first
popular essay on it in 1880 he invented
the word Tesseract for a 4D Cube along
with the words Anna and Kata as the 40
equivalent of left and right that was
all Charles Hinton who also invented the
first baseball pitching machine
although it was powered by gunpowder and
reports differ on how well it worked and
how many injuries it caused Charles was
also convicted of bigamy for being
married to two women at the same time
like I said interesting biography anyway
according to Sebastian when he was
growing up his father Charles built what
was basically a jungle gym out of bamboo
a big structure of Cubes like this and
Charles will get the children to play a
game he'd call out mathematical
coordinates on the grid something like
X3 y2z4 and the kids would have to race
to be the first to get there his logic
was that humans mostly walk around in
two Dimensions but we can understand
three
oh so perhaps if you can get kids to
move around three dimensions intuitively
while their brains are developing they'd
be able to understand four did it work
well not in that way the kids were much
more interested with just playing around
with it as a climbing frame and none of
them apparently developed any
four-dimensional insight but years later
the adult Sebastian patented this it's
one of those inventions that had to
happen at some point if not here someone
else would have figured it out but the
size shape and design that was in school
yards around the world that's down to
Sebastian Hinton his dad and an attempt
to teach the fourth dimension